you're not gonna believe this what is it
recognize this oh yeah that was that
god-awful child actor um Jimmy boy he
did that Christmas movie with Arnold um
jingle cells yeah and that space opera
what was that you always used to say
what me oh yeah that was awful
oh man I was such a bad movie but no do
you know who this is no should I
oh my god
oh well glad to see you're up I thought
you never come to barely move yeah Anna
must have hit you a little too hard must
have not Junior ups out of whack
don't worry about it just keep taking
these pills and feeling will come back
who are you I'm Adam and this is my wife
Jill hello I'm Liz that's the ghost girl
no no that's just our daughter and she's
been a very bad young lady haven't you
Liz maybe I saw her in the woods
she was following you around for a while
while you were up there so you're sorry
Liz sorry what she was whispering
horrible creepy thanks to me yeah she
was trying to scare you while you were
out there so you're sorry Liz sorry but
she was in the corner well she's being
punished we're trying to scare you
say you're sorry Liz sorry somebody
knocked me out
you were an intruder in our house and
you were staring at our daughter Adam
say you're sorry
sorry but as you can see your savior
cameras safe there's nothing to worry
about just rest and you'll feel all
better sleep Liz sorry's 1cv foutch he
did I can't believe it I mean the whole
time the whole time why didn't you tell
us
I don't know but I'm gonna find out you
two keep an eye on the door while I do
some more research do you know about
this queen you're kidding me
the West child actor of all time right
under our noses and that's a single
crack at his expense you don't sit on a
joke that's all I can tell you
rise and shine Jimmy oh my god owner
that names since wait what you call me
Jimmy boy
you're doing fine we know you prefer to
go by Donnie Dupree but starve your
stature never use a false name well it's
been great seeing you guys thanks for
scaring it oh oh your nerves are still
they take more medicine definitely I
don't take more medicine LBX I water
well what a dope hmm there you go you do
not know what an honor it is to have a
star of your name in this house we are
simply thrilled how do you recognize me
we've seen your movies like a gazillion
times yes we recognized your bone
structure my bone structure your movies
were so bad we had to watch them over
and over again it's a family tradition
and we have a surprise for you
galaxy battle the very first bad film
you were ever in a modern no no we're
honoured we get to see one of the worst
space operas of all time we're the worst
child actors of all time you know I
don't think I'm up yes you are yes yes
you're yes you are
no yes report sweetheart hug me help me
yes your girl yeah
yes okay yes yes are you a little bit
more no I guess yeah here comes here
comes you know I think you get worse
every time Jimmy now how can you build
an Android as a kid and yet not
recognize him as an adult I don't know
maybe it's a stupid movie series that
doesn't deserve to be read into well I
got another little surprise for you can
you guess what it is doesn't rhyme with
single hell yeah so I was looking up his
back history on IMDB and well I figured
out that a few bad movies wasn't the
only reason he changed his identity you
want to make some bad shows too
my god his mother threw herself out the
window but why she was middle aged rolls
just dried up being a single mom
divorced battling depression for all
these years I guess it was too much
that's horrible
Donny's career was on the rise it's her
spell
poor kid found out when he was on set
had to shoot the rest of the film with a
fake mother in an Austrian muscle man
what do you suppose something like that
does to a kid it's so funny it's like
you don't care at all are you even
trying it's so terrible there's like no
emotion in your voice what was going
through your head at the time well my
mother killed herself for one died yeah
yeah they didn't talk about that much
they fell to dampen the Christmas spirit
but it happened and I tried to press on
as best as I could under the
circumstances in the end it doesn't
matter because I gave a bad performance
and in the end that is everything I mean
that's enough to judge a person for the
rest of his life for people to shout
things across the street call name say
he's a horrible person because I gave a
bad performance I didn't think acting
was really anything be ashamed oh I mean
I didn't send be hurting anyone I loved
doing it it was following in my mother's
footsteps but in the end no I gave a bad
performance and I should really really
be sorry for it and I am I am so sorry
that I did that can you forgive me
do you forgive me that my mother died
and because of that I couldn't give it
my all
to entertain you because I'm really
sorry about it I am I am so fucking
sorry
haha you almost had me going there for a
minute I was really trying to believe
that someone's would take an acting
lessons no kidding
oh oh here's a scene where you're about
to fly around on Arnold's rocket pack
you can tell only tell by his face that
it's green-screen
well this time all those movies he was
trying to mock I guess it was his way to
vent in Hollywood the whole system 42
years old and already nothing to live
for
how awful it's the way of things
I guess well it's the wrong way all of
it this
we can't let Donnie keep destroying
himself well what do you want to do
let's make a movie um that's what we
always do no I mean a real movie a good
movie oh one of those what you're
requesting is in probably yeah but it's
not impossible
still improbable come on put aside the
freebird Seltzer duo and become the
Welles you were meant to be Quinn give
me my laptop in a six-pack of diet Red
Bull and make sure it's the red flavor
with enough aspirin to give a thousand
rats cancer we've got a movie to make
Christian you want vodka net hell yeah
I'm doing the sober okay time to get you
back to bed yeah you need your rest so
we can watch this again tomorrow how
long do you guys plan on doing this till
you feel better
oh and until when my friends come over
they can watch it with you too it needs
to be big but small dramatic but
relatable and facial inflatable slow
down girl what was that movie should
want me Oscar for uh blue patches about
blind girl meets a black man racist
society doesn't approve they don't get
married
kind of like Helen Keller meets guess
who's coming to dinner
what we'll make it into a sequel a
sequel that someone like Donny would
have wanted to see what are they doing
now oh well once dead and what's kind of
retired I know I mean in the movie Oh
dad who aren't you supposed to give
Jimmy his medicine mm-hmm Edison yeah
like the really important mess in the
heavy narcotics oh my god whoa where'd
he go the fine thing about loss of
relaxers is they had to be taken
consistently in order for them to take
effect especially ones as strong as
these we leave you're just having a
little fun fun yeah we we don't mean
anything by it
you're people you never mean anything by
it when you really think about it when
you don't think about it that you're
bitter debts come out say you're sorry
Liz
sorry don't blame her yeah say you're
sorry Adam
sorry also to blame yeah you took
something that was miserable from the
past and you just obsessed over it you
turn it into your lives but what can't
you think of something that's important
like people or the feelings or no this
is good this is good yeah yeah yeah
listen this is real good cuz you wonder
why you wonder wife I almost became you
I almost became what you are I almost
let something really stupid really
painful really hurtful in the past
consumed me no more I done obsessing I'm
not doing this anymore I don't care what
you do for anything with yours you can
rot in hell for all I care
around that corner stay in that corner
just stay in that corner don't move
don't blink that's not here you can
blink but just just stay there don't
follow me
bye see you again don't over me hmm well
let's go free camp out of this yeah well
tell the greatest love story I'm told a
tribute something for Donny something
for his mother something better than all
this and I'll play the lead you do
realize that's Cameron Diaz and it like
being John Malkovich yeah screw it we
don't have an eight-year-old woman
unless you can kidnap someone from bingo
night quick can we do that uh you can
too risky that's fine
we're down one actor anyway huh Oh
Fabrizio do you have any acting
experience yeah especially under oath
you're in so its coma what have you got
well it's years later and then what
happens watch this
you've come a long way mr. Jordan tell
me what is it you hope to find him
something I've lost most people here
don't get visitors especially after 40
years what madness drove her here love
the sort of deep-seated longing that no
amount of Tears or alcohol or drugs can
ever hope to satisfy if you want to see
her you can but don't hold out much hope
lord knows she has it
I know this space
you've changed world has changed it's
not the same place
I gave you everything my hand in
marriage and you left me I did what I
had to do to protect you the world
wouldn't understand that was my choice
to make mine you were a cow
right
and I'm sorry but now now there's
nothing
come on Leah I can't damn it Elena get
out of this prison and live there's
nothing left for you here there's
nothing for me out there the girl you
knew died on that bus the second it left
the city she's a ghost
just like you
you feel that
it's the same heart that fluttered in
Central Park
the same heart that beats in your chest
so long as you feel that beat we're
alive and that ghosts without a soul
open your ears reach for the sky the
free air again like you once did I'm
scared we're asking but that shouldn't
stop you what if it's too late then
start over
tell me everything new experience like a
newborn baby for the very first time I
feel wind and cold but warmth of the Sun
and your hands and face
I can see it clear as day in my mind
it's beautiful
I have nothing left to offer you just a
broken soul coming to you on bended knee
begging your forgiveness
it's your choice and if you choose not
to I'd understand
but if you'd have of course I do let's
get married under a big tree in Central
Park where
it's the years of abuse the human body
can only take so much
once the orchids start to fail I'm sorry
she has days maybe hours it's not fair
you above all people should know that it
never ends I can do something
I can fix it
now it's my turn
these past few days have been best
I would spend a million lives in
darkness just for this number they're
here with me little last forever
so when you walk out that door
start over
experience everything like a newborn
baby for the first time and tell me what
you see
I see a woman of extraordinary courage a
woman so powerful so beautiful
not even this world can contain her I
see a man who was lost but now is found
was blind but now can see
Wow
that was really good
it was a little cliche that parts but
yeah but for us
oh that citizen fucking Kane for us so
then we just partied the rest of the
night I guess so
so why are you still in a dress I can
take a girl do that yet
I once had a brother who woke up dresses
punky brewster you know what this means
though I should be concerned why my
brother watches Punky Brewster no well
yes but we can make a decent movie yeah
in all it took was a gallon of alcohol
whiskey what a drink we have to save
this this is the best thing we've ever
done I'll take that hey were you I am
Tom Collins grand leader master of swag
I believe this is mine says who okay we
cool we cool I said we cool I even took
out the AL for emphasis this is your
last chance give up demo real or face
the consequences like you're really
gonna kill us not even you're that crazy
really why don't you ask your friend
Donny how crazy I am
you bastard what did you do oh he's fine
maybe she oh you really don't know where
he is do you see I knew it
he's not gonna kill anybody he's
bluffing you're right
there's something I can kill oh that's
the best thing we ever done it's all
we've got
they give up demo real hell no you leave
me no choice
oh hi guys I just want to say that it's
been a blast
oh you're doing another film don't let
me stop you in fact let me get some
things out of your way later how do
these people do here anyway
wait isn't there another person get back
you little bitch you to do three get
back you may have won this round
battles far from over do you hear me the
battle
Danny
here he killed our Christmas gift it's
gonna be something special for you
all right swag you called down the
Thunder well now you've got you see that
it says that I'm a filmmaker take a good
look at swag cuz that's the way you'll
never end up the Swedes are Finnish you
understand me I see a Swedish flag I
kick the ass wearing it so run euchre
run it's all the other terms that Donny
Dubray is coming you tell Jimmy boy is
coming and smells coming with me you
hear sounds coming with me God you think
are going my friend sess King is right
here sure yeah it's a hangout never deal
with some German when deaths is on the
line
color
you keep mad for me a good German never
leaves a comment behind
besides my paycheck
I imagine everybody here has a strange
story to tell that mean well all's well
that ends well that's what I always say
and Danny no we're sorry about pride we
didn't mean to yeah you did
it's okay you know being out there for
those days made me realize something bad
strange stuff can consume people like a
certain group of people I came across
but the way I see it you can either be
taken over by it or you can choose to
move on with your life and I can say for
sure now that I know what's important
who's important and why they're
important so with that said here's to
good times good people and question is
this mint schnapps maybe though I
suppose it doesn't matter because we
have a bottomless supply of Irish
whiskey to fall back on
crook
Oh